[موسيقى]
ولانه منهج الاخوان طول طول تاريخها يقدم
وجوه لكل مرحله سياسيه ولكل تيار يعني حتى
حزب الحريه والعداله ادخل مسيحيين في لما
كان في مرحله النصر والتمكين وكان هذا من
الامور المحرمه سنوات الماضيه موضوع علاقه
يكون الولايه وان يكون هناك قائد من غير
المله التي اييي يعني اسلاميه كما هي
ادبيات الاخوان هم استطاعوا ان يقدم بينهم
حركه همم حركه ثوريه وتسوقوا هذا المفهوم
وبالتالي اليسار العالمي تقاطعه المصالح
والهم يعلمون في الاساس يعني
التقت المصالح بس المحيره الايراني
حركه ثوريه ونحن حركه كوريه وكان هناك
علاقات قديمه
[موسيقى]
مع الاسف
بيبدو بيبدو ان كلامنا يعني في عوده
للوراء لكن انت امام تنظيم بيكرر نفسه هنا
ما يحدث في الماضي من 50 سنه حدث من 30
سنه بيحدث اليوم يا استاذنا يعني في حينما
تحالف الاخوان مع حزب الوفد عام 84 اعترض
افراد الاخوان كيف تتحالف الجماعه مع حزب
على الماني كما يعترض بعضهم اليوم كيف
للجماعه ان تتحالف مع ايمن نور الليبرالي
العلماني نعم رد مرشد الاخوان عمر
التلمساني المشهور في تاريخ الاخواني بعيب
فتيه اللسان قال مطيه لم نجد غيرها
فانتاطيناها
[موسيقى]